Hey, everybody! I'm Sara Bareilles,
and I'm here to talk to you about depression.
It's something I have dealt with in my life.
I know my family members have dealt with it.
I know friends who have dealt with it.
And I bet you do, too.
It is a very complicated and confusing set of emotions and a disease,
and UCLA, my alma mater, is trying to do something about it.
UCLA is launching the largest study on depression in the history of the world.
They are trying to help the over 300 million people who struggle with depression by getting information.
So I'm here to ask you to get involved.
If you are a student at UCLA, you will see information about this on campus, but you can also visit this website:
GrandChallenges.ucla.edu/depression
You share a little bit about your story, a little bit about your emotions, and you can potentially help the researchers
unlock this incredibly difficult thing to deal with.
This is an effort to really understand each other by understanding ourselves.
So get behind this incredible effort by UCLA and share this on social media. Share it with your friends,
get involved, and help this incredible study come to life that can really truly, truly change the world.
Thank you.